oh
awesome
foreign
no
the title is not an exaggeration
the title is a true honest feeling that
I had
at the end of a very bizarre day
a day that seemed like any other
but little as I know what kind of impact
that it would have for the rest of my
life or however long that was going to
last
so I
so there I was
foreign
um minding my own business
what
this is very serious I'm telling a story
that is that a serious ramifications for
the rest of my life
let me have this okay I I did all this I
set this up I got I I let me have this
now I gotta wait for the music to get to
the
very serious hold on
I actually do have a story this time
it's not one of those things where I've
tried to drag it out I'm just trying to
be dramatic about it so let me let's
just start this over yeah let me let me
do this okay hold on
so there I was
a day like any other
and um you guys know that I've been
having like gotten sick I I was in the
hospital a few times my eyes exploded my
ears exploded uh so I I get uh notified
from Evan
that I have a doctor coming over
and it's like a doctor oh that's great
probably to check me up for all the
various ailments that I've had to make
sure that everything is good oh isn't
that nice I think Evan just coordinated
this so I could have this doctor over
here okay so the doctor shows up and
everything's fine everything is like
ordinary like it's a doctor's visit in
my house which is uncommon you know I
don't I don't think house calls are a
thing anymore and that's where my first
suspicion should have been that the
doctor showed up at my house I didn't
ask a reason you know I assumed that if
if Evan tells me something then it's
probably a good thing right
so there's a doctor in my house and they
walk in and they step up you know in my
kitchen
and uh starts asking me questions and
you know this is very standard doctor
procedure right doctor yes the doctor
came to my house so it's a house call
house calls happen house calls happen
very legitimate I didn't ask for any
identification of the doctor but she
seemed nice
that's all I'll say about that started
asking a lot of questions as if this
doctor didn't have any of my previous
medical history right
okay
so I'm asking I'm answering the
questions and it's a lot of questions
it's going into very detailed history of
my medical experiences over the past 10
years really really detailed asked me
like what type of medications I take I
say I have ADHD I take a Stars every day
and it's like that's about it except I
had like this antiviral and antibiotics
and she goes
very nice very nice but
you know you know how it is this is all
True by the way this is actually true
um so I keep asking uh answering
questions and asking questions about
it's like okay what's your uh family
history you know Danny wanna have a
history of heart attack in any one of us
through
like well okay I I may have
I may have had a heart attack but it was
more of a less that there was a problem
with my heart it was like you know that
I was drinking and yada
and then um you know asked about my
family history and then my hospital and
starts asked how many times I've been to
the hospital and then I go into a long
spiel of
how I've been in the hospital
and we go on and go on and then the last
part of this doctor's appointment
is
blood draw in my own home and I go
that's strange
oh well okay I guess uh we're drawn
blood so she busts out her blood draw
kid and she Wham like right in there
grabs a couple vials of blood and I'm
none the wiser I'm none the wiser at
this point I'm none the wiser at any
point in this
um takes the blood puts it in there it
has me sign like all the consent forms
being like we'll tell you what it is a
vampire man
they're trying to clone me you know what
I wouldn't be surprised at this but I
wouldn't be surprised at this so I get
done with all this and it's like you
know a 30 minute appointment lots of
questions lots of History lots of yada
yada but
um I'm assuming that it's going to get
uh to the point where there's
um you know just like am I okay doc do
you do I need anything else like is in
she says okay you'll get all the lab
results back when you get there
um and then she leaves she just leaves
and what she said on the way out was oh
yeah don't worry
um like this is just standard procedure
for a life insurance policy
and I go
left what
I didn't order it
I didn't order a
a life insurance policy
so if you don't know what a life
insurance policy
is if you die
money exists
right okay if you die
money occurs they'll give money to the
the surviving members of your estate
right so you thought I was joking with
this you all thought that I was joking
that this was going nowhere like the
other ones no you you thought this
wasn't going anywhere this is a legit
story that happened the other day so
that doesn't happen though it's
interesting isn't it
so she was just concerned about your
well-being no no no
so I start to look into this
there
I did not request a life insurance
policy a life insurance policy by
someone on my team probably the team you
know the team that recommends all the
games that I play the teams that go on
there someone on my team Somewhere Out
There
set up the dominoes to get me a life
insurance policy
um and the requirement for the life
insurance policy is that I get checked
out my health gets checked out I thought
this doctor was just coming in to give
me a standard checkout because I've been
sick a few times little did I know but
this was a health checkup to make sure
that I wasn't going to automatically
drop dead because then the life
insurance company wouldn't cover me so
now that that's there and once the the
test results come in
there will be
a life insurance policy
somewhere
somehow covering me for a unknown amount
of money because I don't know the amount
of money
because I didn't order this life
insurance
and I maybe I may be jumping to Wild
conclusions I may be jumping into wild
conclusions here but I do believe that
this is the plot of various movies and
or crime dramas where someone pulls out
a life insurance policy for someone else
and
and then little do I know this is the
beginning of a precursor to murder me
and claim that sweet delicious life
insurance policy
right am I being since you're all taking
they're all taking credit for I wouldn't
be surprised okay anyway uh
that that's it that that's it
that's Rippling
I don't know I don't know why uh but I'm
sure it's all fine I'm sure there was
I'm sure I'm sure uh
I'm sure it's all fine I'm 100 sure
everything is okay
hi
hello everyone welcome to the stream uh
I'm back uh from my little break and I'm
gonna get back into the swing of things
but I just wanted to do a live stream
because number one there's been so many
uh strange things that have occurred
um down the road but
there's also just been like
I don't know not enough opportunity for
me to just sit and um chat randomly
about things once three scary games a
hundred I'll come eventually I'm not
dead no but who knows someone might be
plotting My Demise so if you guys figure
out who that is you let me know about
that because there's there's something
there
um this week has been busy uh I haven't
been
getting videos back up and ready mostly
just because I've been editing the movie
um so that's been taking up a lot of my
time
um pretty much every day for the past
week from wake up to go to bed has been
editing the movie
um but it's uh it's getting there it's
getting there it's getting very very
close I'm getting murdered again yeah
the uh the LA gangs are really um
the Heat's making people crazy these
days so that's our gifted one markiplier
membership is that a thing now
I remember that being talked about like
ages ago like gifting memberships would
be possible I didn't know that it was
here
well thank you for doing that I know I
haven't been keeping up with a lot of
things but that's just because
um of all the things that are bad
beginning in my life and you know my
grandma passing and you know me getting
blood in my eyes and then having to go
film some stuff it's been um
it's been a bit of a trip so it's it was
nice to just sit and focus on something
um even if it was just like editing
which I do like editing and I'm I'm
quite good at and you know we're editing
this movie and it's it's very fun and
it's turning out wonderfully uh so it's
um it's been just uh a wonderful moment
it's been wonderful moment of pure work
by wonderful I mean like
it's been grounding you know I mean very
grounding yeah so anyway how are you
guys doing uh yeah that's right I'm
sorry I totally forgot
wait let me
hold on hold on
all right I totally forgot
um
one second one second hold on this is
hold on
okay I'm kicking the music back up this
is important hold on
going dramatic again
I'm on strike
bet you didn't know about that did you
think it was going to be another fake
thing no the truth is I'm on strike I
What's the title of my movie is iron
long
how can you not know that
how do you not know I'm on strike
apparently
um
yeah I'm on strike I'm walking out of my
work I'm not taking this anymore until
my boss treats me with the respect I
deserve
I will not tolerate No I don't mean to
make fun um
sorry
uh yeah but uh I actually I do think I'm
on strike
because I am a member of sag and sag is
the Screen Actors Guild and I am a
member of sag because I've been in Sag
Productions and um so this is where I
don't know how things work because I'm
all I'm all for the strike like yeah
it's it's great to be able to like fight
off have you seen some of the things
that they've been talking about with
wanting to uh scan extras in the
background of movies once and then pay
them once you know a couple hundred
dollars which is usually what background
actors pay get paid if that and a couple
hundred maybe like 200.
um and then use them forever so scan
them once and then using either
technology or AI to recreate them
forever that's what that's the kind of
things that Studios want to do these
days and I know AI is like a contentious
thing these days and for good reason
um so both The Writers Guild and the
Screen Actors Guild are on strike and
I'm part of that so how I'm on strike
everybody
we're gonna we're gonna take it to the I
don't know who I take it to that's the
thing I don't know who I'm going to I
don't know where I pick it I don't know
what I'm supposed to do I know I'm
supposed to be in salt am I even allowed
to stream I don't I don't even know what
I'm doing
um
but it's also interesting because
my movie is a union movie right we did a
union
um mostly just because I wanted to do it
professionally and I wanted to do it of
a certain standard uh so
I'm allowed to stream good okay that
would be weird if I wasn't I I think I I
think I am
um
I'm okay doing live stream good good
that's that's good but the thing is with
the movie I'm not 100 sure how things go
I think I'm fine editing it I don't
think that there's any problem with that
and I'm fine making it because I funded
it and unless I'm striking against
myself I've really got nothing to object
against
um
but it's confusing right because I I've
never really done anything officially in
a screen actor's guild capacity like
Hollywood in general barely gives me the
time of day let alone probably care
about there was some other actor I
forget who it was that made a quote that
was like uh yeah we're going we're going
on strike and like what are these
companies gonna do get a bunch of
YouTubers to play The Avengers
and I'm like well okay I'm on your side
but also hey hold on a second
what did we do to you
what did we ever do to you that was
legitimately a quote like um you know
something like last week and I was just
like well
well hey
hold on
I thought I thought that we okay
Tyler zarnman yeah Anthony Mackey
ah I don't know who that is
but I'm sure they meant well and I'm
sure that
I'm sure that you know
you know not all these divers are jerks
I think I'm kind of nice sometimes
I could I could do it crowdly booper
yeah just like that
um this is an AI Mark God man someday
that probably will happen so there's a
lot of concerns to be had and I get it
you know there's plenty of people out
there that are worried about what
um technology and like these AI models
are going to do for their future in
terms of entertainment and yeah it's
it's concerning and there's a lot of
like rules that need to be put in place
before the landscape actually gets to a
point where it's uh kind of too late so
it's it's an opportune moment to be able
to do this
um like I just want to be able to get my
movie out to you guys I want to be able
to show you iron lung I actually have a
trailer that is almost ready that I'm
going to be showing to you prove that
I'm the real Mark I don't know if I can
I I don't know if I can
how do I prove to you that I'm really me
how would you know I mean this is a this
would be pretty impressive if there was
something able to do this but how would
you really know
say a line see that's something an AI
model would do if it was just like
something I say all the time it would be
really good at training on that that'd
be something that it would really train
bring chica nah
nah I couldn't do that do two back flips
I don't know if you think who I think
you think I am boar Spirit the bore
Spears right there I don't feel like
getting it I feel I don't have legs
right now and I don't feel like that's
that's pertinent to everything it is
stand up I couldn't ever do that
why would you ask me that that's so
incredibly rude of you to do that yeah
so unbelievably rude actually if you
think about it yeah
um but so long as I'm able to get you
know my keep continue working on my
movie because that's the thing I don't
even know if like because I I gotta like
you know occasionally record a little
line to like cover anything in my own I
don't know it's not like there's a
production company making my movie it's
just me like it's just it's just me so I
don't know do I strike against myself I
don't know what to do I don't know
anything to do
but um I think as far as it goes is like
because it's not a studio thing it's
just me
um there's really nothing symbolic or in
solidarity for me to strike against
myself and not make this because in all
honesty the reason I'm making it is very
much for just the Artistic integrity of
making it I like what I do and I like
making these projects so there's um
there's really nothing strike against my
boss
I'ma strike me so hard later I'm gonna
strike all over me I'm going to be
picking up and down my driveway
um yeah
so uh yeah there's that
uh what is happening uh there's a plot
to murder me probably someone took out a
life insurance policy on me true facts
um and it wasn't me so there's someone
plotting to murder me and also I'm on
strike so let me update my my little um
so
murder strike you know oh that's that's
unreadable
so I'm on murder strike
um I'm I'm striking for murders I'm
walking away from all murders I ain't
murdering again until we get good murder
conditions I'm not doing a thing
yeah
in fact
I already died wait hold on what are you
talking about
what do you mean Act
Ive I wouldn't be dead
how did I do that how did I do what
I'm striking for murder
I'm just not gonna murder I'm not doing
it don't ask me to do it I'm not doing
it right now there's no way I'm doing it
so no no way not at all it's like he's
still here
oh yeah yeah you guys can go watch who
killed Markiplier if you want that
um and uh that could be that could be
all that oh yeah also there was um so
there was like this Tick Tock that blew
up I actually deleted Tick Tock so I'm
not up to date on all the the memes um
but this Tick Tock came out like right
when I got back from uh Korea so I
didn't even see it for a while
um but it was talking about this old
video that I had on my channel that was
about this game called uh the hospital
which was a strangely confusing thing
for a lot of people because I just made
an update video that was called I'm in
the hospital so this um this video came
out on Tick Tock about this game because
apparently it actually had Gore in it
um which for some reason I didn't know
at the time but when I went back and
looked at it I was like oh God yeah that
oh yeah so I I just deleted the video
because I don't give a about it um
but it was such a fascinating thing uh
be because like obviously yeah it's not
good whatever don't support the game
yada yada but the chat or it's not chat
the comments section of that video I
have no idea why
but they were just they were using it
like twitch chat you guys you were using
it like twitch chat and I couldn't
understand where this world came from to
be like you know uh this video comes out
a little oh I was videos came out real
Gordon and I'm like I'll just delete it
whatever but then people were in the
comments just talking
in real time as if it was chat did you
guys see that were you part of that why
what led to this circumstance that this
would be
this would be there
he knows of course I know how could I
not know you guys always think that I
don't notice thing or don't say things
usually I just like well I'm not gonna
make an apology video like oh man seven
years ago where's my ukulele eyes I
can't even oh man how could I do such a
it's like whatever it was
but you guys
what were you doing in the comments
section down there why not though I
don't know I guess not yeah it is
so I don't know it's just like it is
what it is
um but that was just like I've never
seen that before I've never seen
just in in the strange circumstance
where it's like someone made a video
about this whole video and then people
just decided to use the comments for
their own role play sessions and I'm
like oh this is bizarre but all right so
uh did I get a haircut
um when we did some of the extra shots I
had to get it trimmed back that's why
I've kept my hair long is just in case
we need to you know film anything else
and and we do occasionally
um you never know uh so I'm keeping it
long but man I'm sick of it it's just it
got trimmed so it's now right back to
the perfect fall right in my mouth
length and it just it had just gone past
that and I was like oh thank goodness I
don't have to worry about this
again and then suddenly oh it got
trimmed and now I'm back right in my
mouth
huh anyway I'm gonna be murdered
um I'm on strike and I'm not murdering
anymore period but that doesn't stop
people that are not in the murder Union
for murdering me so that would be really
that would be inappropriate but it could
happen you know it could happen
yeah exactly
yeah
so um it is what it is uh uh where's
2016 hair I don't even remember what
that hair was I don't even know what
that is I know and what I'm gonna do is
right after the stream I'm gonna put up
the next video of Amnesia because and
this is where you guys are going to be
very mad at me I've actually had that
done that's been done for a while I
just wasn't uploading it I get in this
weird bad habit of like a video be ready
to go but I'll be like Oh I'm not right
in the mindset to go into recording
again so I didn't just have that video I
had three videos that were done ready to
roll ready to rock 100 good ready to go
even a one out of thumbnail done I just
didn't press public and it was like it
was just a thing where I was like ah man
but if I'm not able to keep this up then
I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna be able to keep it up and
then it'll just be another pause again
so I like to wait until I'm like ready
to record more and then I do that but I
didn't do any I didn't do either of them
so yeah you lost out on video but it's
there I'm gonna I'm gonna right after
this
I'm gonna get it up and you guys are
gonna see it
yeah uh no the the title is not a lie
well I mean it's it's not the truth
either so I don't know what it is I can
go I can do the story again I put all
this work in it okay it was like hang on
let me let me get back into it
is that playing
I think it's playing okay hold on
I'm gonna do the thing again
all right I'm gonna make it more
dramatic though wait let's make it more
dramatic hold on nope not that
all right
hold on I don't know what voice effect
this is
hello
so there I was too deep
so there I was so there I was
I thought it was a normal day
I woke up that morning on the right side
of the bed thinking that my life
wouldn't be changed forever
and little did I know
and later that very afternoon someone
would walk in my front door they would
reveal conspiracy
during my life
this is a true story nothing that I'm
saying is making is being made up you
can ask everyone else in chat if you
didn't hear this story you're hearing it
from me
this is true
house calls aren't made anymore not
usually doctors don't like to go to
people's houses
it's inconvenient for them kind of kind
of thing
but that day
a doctor showed up to my house
funny
I didn't call for a doctor I was told by
Evan you know
you probably know heaven
trustworthy reliable
or so I thought
or so it's thing new
and this doctor
started asking me questions questions
about my health questions about my life
questions about my father and my mother
and my brother
and myself how many times have I been to
the hospital many
how many times have I had a heart attack
one
am I well
am I healthy
that's what I thought that morning
then this doctor took out a needle that
was shot now okay I don't want to
exaggerate started to draw my blood
put a needle in my arm filled two vials
bright red blood gushing out of my arm
filling it
and yeah filling it filling files that
is and then the doctor was done
doctor walked out the door and said
don't worry
you'll hear your adults soon
and then your life insurance policy
will be approved depending on the
results
life insurance policy
I didn't take out a life insurance
policy
I didn't even think that this was about
a life insurance policy
I just I set all this up I literally
spent so much time setting this up
I spended like 30 minutes
before I started the stream setting this
up that's what I did I put in so much
work into it
putting so much work in anyway so yeah
oh you did were you in was it good it
was getting good
it was good
Oh I thought you I thought you were
being sarcastic
[Music]
someone in my life took out a life
insurance policy
Paul on me for millions of dollars
millions and millions and millions of
dollars probably
but it wasn't me
and I know it's probably oh you've seen
one too many movies oh you've seen one
too many Crime TV shows but
why would someone take out a
multi-million dollar life insurance
policy on me
well I'm still alive
suspicious suspicious
it's pretty spooky right it's good right
it's good you guys are it's good right
you tell me if it's not good like if
this is if this wasn't enhancing the
story in any way I'll be really upset
about that because of how much work I
put into all of this I put the text on
the screen
after the music tip I cut that music up
so it looped longer so I could build out
the story and I could Pat it out okay if
it wasn't good then I'm just waiting to
get everybody's time okay all right cool
good good it's a true story
I'm breaking the Emir I'm sorry okay
so later that night
I'm sleeping man
I thought I locked all the doors
I thought I locked all the windows
but then I woke up in the middle of the
night
and no one was there
no one
chica wasn't there
maybe it wasn't there
almost there
I was alone
except for the person standing in the
corner of the darkness
staring at me
hidden in Shadows
but I could still see their eyes
bright gleaming at me
wide as if afraid
and I stared back
and then I woke up all right I don't
have an end to that all right cool all
right we're done we're all caught up
okay what is it uh
uh ooh I know how to make this even
better everyone shut up something's
amazing is about to happen everyone
quiet something incredible is about to
occur hold on
Hold On Shut
shush
shush be silent
no
[Music]
no shush
amazing things are occurring
you wish you knew what was happening
all right hold on
shush
uh
hard to find
hold on shush uh Vamp talk with each
other for a moment I gotta find
something
uh
that's the one this is gonna make it
okay cool I'm onto something now oh
that's great oh that's wonderful oh
that's great
that's really good
okay cool
all right this is great
this is wonderful I love this
and I'm super happy about it
um okay cool very cool actually very
cool hold on
hold on
wait for it
okay cool wait hold on
it's gonna be worth it it's gonna be
super worth it
gonna be very worth it
hold on
okay here we go
we're just gonna put that there
right there
just there we go
that's good why can't I rotate that here
we go
there we go
come on rotate damn you rotate rotate
rope rotate
rotate there we go
there we go
that's nice right
why I put so much work into getting this
in here I put the production value into
this Stream So you get entertainment at
every turn now it's so much spookier
it's so much more there's something
behind me ah you right God damn it I put
I'm a good streamer
oh my God
I'm really good at the streaming thing
you can be mean
you're being mean to me I'm doing a good
job
doing a good job I'm doing a good job
look it's all spooky here's here's a
scary picture oh
good all right look I put in so much
work into these streams you don't
understand the amount of effort that I
put into this and the amount of effort
that is wasted if you don't appreciate
every moment of it you know I'm really
stepping up my content I'm stepping it
up stepping up my content
and if you just are gonna laugh at me if
you're gonna laugh at my spooky
spookiness
don't deserve what I'm doing good
remove them why
what's wrong with them too scary is it
too scary for you is it too scary I bet
I bet it is very scary it's very scary
all right cool
anyway
uh uh next part of the story is holy
crap
um
it's still difficult to get
prescriptions that's been a problem
good really good uh but that's a story
that like I was dealing with like a year
ago and still even dealing with that's
the only thing other thing new in my
life there's there's really nothing else
new so I got like nothing else to talk
about but boy howdy is it still
difficult to be able to do uh literally
anything in terms of getting medications
um and I don't know if it's just the CVS
that's near me or something but the
person who works there is also
incredibly mean all the time for no
reason I'm like isn't it
isn't this I get that probably people
come in and they're mad all the time but
I'm not mad I don't get mad
I don't get mad I know I know I gotta
stop using but I'm so lazy
but I'm so lazy
but that doesn't stop the fact that
there was the whole prior authors oh
whatever I'm so lazy I'm so lazy
they took out the insurance on me I wish
now I wish that I don't know what you
mean by that but I wish man Korean
Healthcare was just like amazing it was
such a breath of fresh air to be able to
get that and I know that like ADHD
prescriptions are are a bit more tightly
controlled there but my latest
prescription they they would do they
would do it and it's it's just like
you don't understand what's happening
I'm streaming
that's what's happening
that's what's happening right now
that's 100 what has happened
yeah
oh anyway
it's not lazy it's busyness I don't know
it's probably a little bit of both I am
extremely busy but when it comes to
changing like things that I need to
change I often don't do it what does
this look like if I don't if I don't
have the
what does that look like oh that's
better that's better that's nice that's
nice yeah I do have a bit of the full
far quad going on right now like I I
it's it's just this particular length
and cut is just
it's not my best hair that I've ever had
and and I could do more but again I'm
extremely lazy absolutely lazy yeah
[Music]
um
ruin DLC release date is that today does
FNAF security breach DLC come out today
thank you thank you I'm not fishing for
uh compliments here CBS sponsorship God
can you imagine the power
I I literally am like right now I'm like
oh man I I wouldn't mind like a sponsor
or something but then I've been like
that for a long time and I'm very bad at
sponsorships so I don't do it uh or I
don't get them anyway and I don't get a
lot of them I could get a lot of them
but
but I do say no to quite a few because I
don't think that they're quality but
whatever yeah also what's gonna happen
what do you mean what's gonna happen
what do you mean what's happening you
know what's happening
is there something happening oh the
murder right I talked about that right
that's all fine
[Music]
no raid Shadow Legends uh I mean I'm not
super interested in in that because I
don't really play it so I don't have
there turn off the Ikea what's wrong
with the lights
what's wrong with the lights
I put so much work into these lights I
did not put any work into that lights I
just wanted to be it was more dramatic
when it was all black and white that's
what it was
yeah
but I didn't get I didn't get what I
needed God the hair
yeah
oh what is this game suggestions coming
in didn't you read the rules
didn't you read the rules there's no
game suggestions there's no game
suggestions allowed listen if you can
hold off from saying a single game
suggestion I'll watch the Five Nights at
Freddy's trailer I'll do it but if you
if I see a single game suggestion for
the next five minutes I'm never seeing
it I haven't seen it yet and I'm never
gonna see it and I don't even know what
it is I don't know it's I'm never gonna
watch it
if I get if I see a there's another one
okay I guess we're not doing it then
it's too late everyone
failed and here I was gonna reveal all
the secrets
but I'm not getting there
in there thoughts on thoughts I don't
even know what that means
thoughts on thoughts thoughts on
thinking I think real good I like
thinking thinking thinking's high
quality thinking's great thinking is
wonderful yeah
thinking is just it's so good
the lights are a little loud yeah I know
it's dramatic or something I don't know
it's dramatic yeah absolutely uh oh if
you guys didn't know when I I made a
video just a little bit ago I I realized
this in a for some reason like a lot of
other uh YouTubers don't realize this
here's a little secret into everything
is
um not every person watches every video
that you'll put out I don't know why
that's such a common misconception but
for some reason if people get like a
consistent number of views on YouTube
people seem to think that it's the same
number of people coming back for every
video and that's just not the case
that's just absolutely not so even if I
put out a video the reason I say it so
much or repeat myself so much is because
even in a stream like this the amount of
people coming in and out is astonishing
uh the number of people that are
floating in and out of the stream it's
the number can stay fairly consistent
but that doesn't mean it's the same 28
000 people or so that are here it's it's
a lot of people flowing in and out and
it's the same thing with other videos so
that's why I repeat myself so much is
because even if you got the information
someone out there didn't I just want to
make sure everyone is informed I'm like
an apple commercial you just repeat the
same buzzwords over and over and over
again and people people get the message
eventually
I get there eventually I'm such a good
YouTuber
I am a good YouTuber I'm great I'm I'm
incredible I'm great yeah I'm an apple
see this is where the listening also
just doesn't occur on the other half you
guys have to hear properly and take in
the information I'm giving you for it to
have any meaning and that's also why I
many many many times
uh what's my opinion on mental illnesses
uh I'm not an authority to speak on
these things the only thing I have
experience with is ADHD and you can say
you can see how literally anything I say
gets misconstrued now I am officially an
apple in people's minds and they will
carry that on for a while depending on
the traction of these things that might
carry on for anywhere from a day to uh
three years from now people will still
be like you're an apple
you remember and I'll be like I don't
actually I don't remember anything
so I don't often like like my opinion on
it is uh is there's that's such an open
question that I have no idea even how to
answer it even if I did know what I'm
talking about but then again I try to
speak only on things that I do know
unless I am talking about the wild
conspiracy that I'm
someone's plotting my murder which is
something I will talk about at any
opportunity
now
I am the authority
I don't think I'm the authority on uh
mental illnesses I don't think that
that's me what's in the right corner I
have no idea what do you mean what are
you talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
I don't know
thoughts on Markiplier great guy
shares uh could be a little higher on
his videos but everything else they're a
little low this month yeah
anyway
there is a new Joy of creation well
that's great to know but that sounds
like a game suggestion also if you might
have uh I don't know if this one came in
no it hasn't come out yet I speaking of
Apple
you guys know I've been like Windows for
a very long time right
you guys know this right I'll get let me
test the water real quick let me let me
let me test the water here let's just
let's just start a poll uh which
oh got it oh man uh
okay I'm just just chucking it out there
just just chucking it out there just
Chuck it just choking
I should I probably should have said PC
damn
that is
that is incredibly that is a huge
discrepancy
it's actually it's like 90 to 10. it's
like a huge ratio majority windows
I know I spelled witch front that's not
the focus of this that's not the focus
of it that's not the focus of it
that's not the focus
anyway
so I've recently made the big switch
I've made the well okay I haven't made
that much of a switch I'm this is a PC
right here but
I
have recently discovered the glory and
the incredible
horsepower and uh convenience of Mac
computers
I have done it
I have done it I made the switch
I've betrayed the PC Master race I've
done it I'm off I'm gone and you know
why you know why
do you know why
it's because
as much as I've been using Windows for
I've done it it's too late it's done
don't get on my back about this because
it's too late you should ask me before
when Windows was causing me all these
problems and yet here we are standing at
the precipice of glory and you can't
even see the glory ahead of you you're
looking at me acting like I'm the
traitor when you're betraying yourself
by not giving yourself the chance okay
this this actually
I have some opinions on this I have some
opinions on this okay I have some
opinions are you ready for opinions
because I know I've kicked the Hornet's
Nest and I know you guys are all up in
arms about this and look all you Windows
fan boys out there are all clutching
your your PCS oh my goodness I can't
believe it look
you remember those old Mac commercials
that are Apple commercials it was like
I'm a Mac I'm a PC okay back then it was
garbage okay I'm gonna I'm gonna say
this straight up all you wind oh Mac
Fanboys that thought I was in your
corner look a mat uh a Mac four years
ago was trash there was no good Mac and
there was definitely no good Mac for a
good price 100 even just I'm talking
just four years ago four years till
Beyond Mac garbage total trash that is
absolutely awful there was no redeeming
qualities you couldn't game on it you
couldn't do any It people were like it's
bird Friday it wasn't and like get over
it you wasn't
um
however
whose side am I on listen that's the
moral of the story you don't need to
pick a sign but but
that has changed that has changed and
I'll tell you why tell you why I got a
Macbook a little bit ago earlier this
year I got a Macbook
um I actually had a Macbook before that
but it wasn't the new M chip MacBook I
was in Korea just recently and if you
didn't know I made a documentary
um about my family called Markiplier
from North Korea where's the Loyalty
loyalty shmuelty
loyalty shmuelty schmoilty I say but I
was in Korea right and I made this
documentary and I wanted to re-edit it
and get it re-rendered in a way that I
could uh put some machine translation
over it so at least my family could read
it even if it wasn't good translation
right at least they could understand it
and see it and get some of the story
right so I had this MacBook that I
bought this year in January I believe
when it came out I bought it um because
I like it for writing and it was nice
for writing and I was like okay at least
the redeeming quality of this is I can't
do anything but I'll write on it
I wasn't even plugged in I was not
plugged in on this MacBook I was not
plugged into a wall I was purely on
battery I opened up the entire
documentary working with raw video files
raw video files on this laptop at full
4K resolution which is not even that
crazy but if I was doing that on a
Windows PC on battery nothing would
happen it wouldn't go anywhere and I was
doing all of this I was doing all of it
on battery
I started at 100 I was working on it for
like maybe five hours and I did all this
like I re-edited it reformatted it like
put the machine translations re-rendered
it all
and it rendered at 300 frames a second
it was never stuttered never had a
problem never it did anything five hours
I was working on that video editing on a
laptop with no problems I uh when it was
done rendering I still had 54 battery
left
I've never experienced that never in my
life have I experienced that and all you
people with Mac was like you could have
done that it's like you couldn't have
done that your performance would have
been garbage but the performance is good
the performance was great better
actually than if my laptop my Windows
laptop was plugged in all right okay and
this is where loyalty is shmuelty and
that's what I'm saying like that loyalty
doesn't matter you get the right tool
for the job and right now holy crap
Mac is the right tool for the job if you
do video editing if you do any kind of
content Creation with video involved
even like photo editing like you what if
you're not on Mac you are losing out
because it is amazing it is it changed
my perception of what it could be
it changed my loyalty loyalty if it's
your job to do these things you got to
get the right tool for the job right you
have to you have to get the right tool
for the job yeah what about Linux
there's no programs work on Linux get
out of here get out of here oops this is
the Linux all right let's get it wow
let's get a new poll oh let's get a new
poll here all right okay all right uh
no that's a q a I don't know what I'm
doing I'm a Linux guy get out of here we
wanted to go build a server Linux man
yeah okay all right all right we'll see
when you get that infrastructure built
all right when you have to code it from
the ground up let me talk to me lad yeah
okay
uh
Linux
there we go
okay all right there it is
I I use Linux I love reinstalling my
operating system because I love doing
that look some of us actually have jobs
to do I know the line look guys some of
those actually make things yeah yeah
some of us actually that was actually
aspire to achieve in life and others of
us we use Linux
ah
[Music]
what's up you thought there were no
games on Mac
man
Lennox just they haven't even heard of
gaming I think they got doomed to work
finally yeah I think I think that worked
out
anyway
so uh yeah no I'm I'm I'm fully
converted except that I'm not at all
because this is being streamed on
um
PC
so that's it yeah anyway
oh how do we get from Apple I was
talking about something else I was
talking about prescriptions I was
talking about trouble with that
nothing else there I don't know any bad
guy questions for me that are nothing to
do with games I'll take I'll take
questions now I'll take can I do that is
that a thing
all right um what uh ask me
uh what ask me me answer
me answer good
I've never done an actual like q a
before I don't even know how you do what
what did I do
how is this better
are you guys seeing the same thing I am
are you
what is that
is that happening to you
it's going by a million miles an hour
it's going faster than ever I can't read
anything
are you seeing this
am I the only one experiencing this
nightmare
what is happening
how is this occurring
how does anybody
is this a feature is this supposed to be
a good feature
you guys aren't seeing this right now
what's happening is Chad is going
and all the questions that have been
asked in the entire stream are just
being blasted on Loop they're just being
anything with a question mark that was
ever on stream it's just
it is this is the most useless thing
I've ever seen
I've never I ha what
I can't even huh
what is that all right anyway
um
well I'm gonna end that q a because
that's
um in the question list what question
list
what do you mean question list
I'll just see a question list
what are you talking about
there is no question list
it's just it's just a blur
anyway whatever it's bad all right I'm
ending that
look it was not okay I'm telling you it
was not okay I I just ended it and it
finally there literally every question
that had ever been asked in this chat
blasted by it a million miles an hour
yeah I forgot how to computer yeah I
accidentally touched
the Linux operating system and then my
IQ dropped like 30 points and I wasn't
able to remember how to even operate a
computer it's shocking that I even
turned it on to be honest yeah so it's
uh yeah it's it's probably good I I need
to just like make sure that there's like
a hundred foot perimeter between me and
anything Linux related for uh
for at least the rest of my life for
however long it is until I get murdered
yeah
anyway
please God I just want him to mention
iron lungs existence at this point
I was talking about it I thought wasn't
I talking about it
what am I talking about
now we're not talking about it
I thought I was talking about it
yeah absolutely I think I did anyway
there's a trailer that's um soon soonish
soon ish is what I would say about that
so uh right after this I'm gonna get the
Amnesia up don't worry about that oh
yeah I'm on strike that's right I am on
strike so I am on strike that is a thing
yeah
opinion on marching senior year I don't
I don't don't do it
don't
don't do it
sun is the forest I also have sons of
the forest all right I'll give you a
chance this is a weird moment where you
guys actually get to influence what
happens next on my channel this very
rarely ever happens uh what video should
be next because both videos are ready
and ready to go
Amnesia sons of the forest or uh
this uh nah okay I'll just leave it at
that no it's it's just this too it's
this too
the DS2
all right so I'm putting up a poll
whatever it is I will abide it is law it
will be set down as law
what is it
what do you got for me
ah so I'm seeing that more people want
sons of the forest which means that
people are more excited for Sons of the
forest which means that people will be
more willing to wait for Sons of the
forest
gotcha amnesia's coming up next Get
Wrecked all you Linux users who like
sons of the forest I bet you all use
Linux I bet you're watching this on some
bootleg like totally custom coated box
that hacks into the YouTube Mainframe
you Linux losers
oh anyway uh go back to your penguin
mascot anyway Amnesia is coming up next
Boom the all you Amnesia lovers you
really were the true fans you were the
true true fans you're the real
subscribers that's who you really are
not like those fake subscribers over
there they don't even count as a
subscription because I don't think
YouTube even accepts a connection from a
Linux PC that's not even a PC
bucks or whatever they call it anyway
you you Amnesia lovers you're the
winners you're the real winners you're
the winners congratulations on being
smart and beautiful handsome or and
anyway well done well done on being on
the right side of History
anyway
yeah what what's going on
let's end this poll all right good pull
good pull guys
um so what else was I going to talk
about I don't even know I don't even
know anymore
I don't know about anything I need some
sleep tonight I do not sleep well I did
not sleep well
it's been a little difficult like uh
because I haven't been able to get like
a a prescription so I don't know if
you've been able to tell but
a little um less attentive than I
usually am I'm a little more tired
that's the thing that's okay I'm trying
to keep up with other stuff I gotta get
back into working out again I was very
strong I was very very strong did I tell
you I benched 225 I did that for the
first time in my life bench 225.
oh man that was good times and then I
lost all of my strength
not all of it but a lot of it I need to
work out again I need to get big and
strong opinion on depleted uranium
pleated uranium
it it's
what a fascinating material I suppose I
don't know what uh opinions I should
have on that I have not become informed
enough I'll say that yeah I'll say that
yeah
talk about the Titanic submarine I mean
at this point it's so long ago there's
like it's already fallen out of people's
minds but you know it was interesting
um because obviously when that was
happening iron lung was trending
that was weird
um and it's not really a thing where you
can like oh yeah let's lean into this no
let's not
um but at the same time there were so
many people like oh god oh no Mark's
Gonna Cancel the movie and I'm like
why would you think that wait no of
course I'm not gonna cancel the movie no
in weirdly it just like it it weirdly
brought more attention to iron lung
which was a bizarre thing
um and you know David was talking about
that on Twitter just being like yeah
this is super weird there was a spike in
sales for the game don't know how to
feel about that and like so many people
wrote articles about him and like he was
tweeting out that is like yeah it's kind
of uh odd and uncomfortable
um and it's just like yeah it is kind of
weird
um
so that's the strange coincidence
oh well
but I'm not gonna cancel it I'm not
gonna there's no reason to cancel this
movie about a submarine just because a
submarine imploded
doesn't make it doesn't make it a taboo
it doesn't make it oh no it's completely
unrelated they just aren't connected by
submarines the movie isn't a story about
what happened to them it's just a
different story technically there's
precedent so let's get started came
first
exactly
yeah
did the uh did the did the five nights
DLC come out
is that out now
is that out
when does it arrive
when
tell me
on the 25th what day is it 15th ah
interesting uh interesting
all right I'll play that yeah I'll play
that I'll do that
opinion on regular uranium oh you know I
don't really know about that
I don't know
I don't know how am I I feel like no one
else has asked you that yet oh that's
very sweet of you but I I am good I
appreciate you I'm sure someone is asked
but I just haven't seen it uh I am
honestly doing uh quite well
um there's I know I was saying like I'm
tired I need sleep stuff like that and I
know like yeah I just like Grandma
passed away but really truly like I I am
doing good I am very very
um
very very cognizant of the situation and
I took plenty of time to myself and then
I was focused on the things that I
needed uh to get their shingles shingles
all better yes shingles all better
caught that early enough did you guys
did I talk about that I got I got
shingles like
just the most bizarre random thing
Chicken Box decided is we um I'm back
that can happen
um yeah so yeah lots and lots of
shingles eyes
ear infection
um
and yeah it's just like it spends time
but I am doing good I I am I am really
good I am I I just would like to get my
prescription there because it's not even
like I know there's a shortage of like a
lot of other ADHD medications but there
is not a shortage of this one I think it
really is just like this my Pharmacy
that I go to is just a really truly
terrible Pharmacy who's uh pharmacist
and I always hate to say this is like
but the pharmacists just don't seem to
care there they're always mean they just
don't seem to ever care and I get it
like it's it's a job and you probably
hate your job and that's that's fine but
it's like I I kind of need some of these
things these need some help
depending on the Korean Healthcare
System I think I I talked about it it's
just like it's very good yeah and it is
it's just one of those things where
I've I've been very very cognizant and
I've been thinking about this because
obviously I I've said many times that I
want to make a video talking about my
experiences with ADHD and like trying to
like talk about it in a way that doesn't
lean into the misconceptions about it
and also not not trying to like talk
about it in a way that's like oh it's
just horrifyingly crippling thing it is
obviously a thing that affects my my
everyday life
um but it's it's one of those things
that I deal with and it's the other
thing that's like exercise and
meditation and like proper diet and
doing these other things they are all
factors that help
um but they're all part of the same like
treatment that you need from a medical
professional that being said I do have
like vastly more opinions
um on medications than I did and I do
think that there are some medications
that are good for it and there are some
medications that are bad for it
um in terms of if it's actually like a
medication can't fix
the problem it can get you like on track
to start building the habits to address
um the things in your life that lack
structure and create the habits that
build into those things and that's why
legitimately I do like the medication
that I'm on now because it isn't a pill
that just
suddenly I've got the focus of a God and
that's never like what it's been for me
um but yeah it's it's help it's not a
fix and that's why I constantly says
like uh it's it's something that's for a
medical professional and yeah meds are
all different meds work for certain
people in certain ways and um these
these kind of things do
take time and it's it's always been
something that I've been hesitant to
talk about in a way without knowing more
but I'm almost to the point where I'm
like okay I got this
so I can I can speak to this with some
more understanding
um because I have a greater
understanding of myself and I think like
that's that's what it all amounts to is
just understanding yourself and
understanding what you want because
obviously like I've dealt with this my
whole life essentially and gotten
started to help it for the past like 11
or so years
um but when it boils down to whether or
not it's going to stop me from doing
anything I want to do it's like that's
that's not it you still have to get
there I like I like the medication I'm
on because it feels more like I can be
at that Baseline I'm not pushed into the
some Zone that's like oh yeah I'm able
to be extremely I'm fixed I'm cured
because that's never what it is it
allows me to feel normal
and that that alone that alone
is wonderful it allows me to feel like
I'm at a baseline that I have the same
platform that everyone else does I'm not
like unbelievably a god at Focus or
anything but it gets me to the point
where the detrimental effects of ADHD
are not unbearable and I'm at the normal
level of man I'm just I don't feel like
it you know it could because that is
normal that's that's the other thing is
like that is very normal people just in
general that is a normal way of being no
one out there is walking around being
like I am doing everything that I want
to do in my head instantly with no
qualms it's just like yeah it's uh it is
that thing where I'm very very I I like
what's going on now and it's getting to
the point where I feel more confident in
the trajectory that I'm building these
habits for and it's
this is nice
that's nice
it is very nice yeah yeah meds helped me
out start more of a neutral headspace
instead of my brain making me hate
myself so much all the time that is it
yeah it's like all I want to do is get
to neutral
um so that I can build habits that get
there and then the times when it's like
you know even even without medication
like you'd be able to have those habits
to rely on because habits are very
strong and if you can build the habits
they really do last they last quite a
while so it's it's that's infinitely
more important
opinion on Hollywood strike uh excuse me
I'm on strike
I am a member of sag and so I'm on
strike
from
the things that I wasn't part of but I I
am a big supporter of this right kind of
I'm all about it yeah
sure moves boss
well I guess that's possible
I've never actually been in a strike
before so this is my first strike so
yeah that's good
what do I do on strike I could
technically speaking go to picket lines
and go outside Studios and and demand uh
equal treatment but also I I'm I'm not a
I'm not in those spheres I am in Sag but
my latest movie was uh my production
that I paid for and directed and wrote
and um acted in
um so it's it's
I can't strike against myself I've never
really been in a
you know a Hollywood production so I
don't know I really it's kind of still
to this day like a world outside of me
yeah
maybe striking at the end of September
um striking till or is this another
group striking yeah
which is good striking is good like um
it really just shows that like yeah the
power's in the people that is what it is
yeah
um
um well with that being said
what is the strike it's a Striker's uh
it's a strike for the writer's Guild and
the Screen Actor Guild for actors in
movies and stuff and TV shows they're in
Sag and the writers of those shows are
in the writer's Guild and so they
negotiate on behalf of all the writers
in the guild to get better pay and you
know health benefits and stuff like that
for there so this is there darkiplier
YouTube's figure yes there will be a
dark player YouTube's figure
um coming up
I don't know if there was an official
announcement about that did you just
guess that and I said it I think there
might have been something teased about
that it's coming out I'm spoiling it
whatever I'm spoiling it
I'll just spoil everything there's
there's darkiplier YouTube's coming out
um
duh man let's spoil the whole FNAF movie
uh
I could but I won't
um
what else could I spoil
I don't know plenty of stuff
opinion on hello neighbor VR I just
don't care about that game I don't care
man I stopped caring about that game
when like the third version of came out
of it came out and it was even worse
than before nothing in my mind
comprehends why that game is in any way
popular has any kind of a following or
is any way like
positively received I don't understand
it I don't get it and it is unless
there's been some groundbreaking thing
uh it is still in my mind a terrible
game and I I just like
I don't understand how it's still around
at this point I don't understand in the
least how that survived
um being as bad as it was because it was
pure and simple
bad and look I'm always on the side of
like yeah support the game developers
and like it's hard to make games and I'm
not going to be making games I haven't
done it that game was bad everyone can
tell it's not worth the money and
pointing anyone towards it is just like
a bad it's not good so I'm not gonna do
that yeah
now trapped in sewer now that's a game
for the ages now I tell you what trapped
in sewer might be my game of the year
2023 100 beautiful in every way you
wanna you wanna get a good game that's
gonna give you all the value in the
world for that price tag how about the
beautiful price of zero dollars baby you
got trapped in suit coming at you hot
and heavy updates flying off the shelf
me and my team my entire Team stand 100
behind trapped in sewer you want to get
a good game you want to get a good video
why don't you hop off the stream right
now go see trapped in sewer because
that's gonna be worth your time and
worth your money at zero dollars
is
no
talk about things get away from me
the whole thing that's always gives away
anyway can't wait for security breach
can't wait for all the other things
can't wait to be rid of these demons
that are haunting me uh and then I'm
gonna get back in the thing so I'm gonna
get out of here
thank you so much for uh being a part of
this and look forward to uh Amnesia
coming out
oh locked in Seward oh oops
um
locked in sewer
[Music]
oh boy locked in sewer
man I know what I'm talking about most
of the time I thought it was trapped in
sewer locked into Earth locked I don't
remember all right I'm out have a good
night guys bye